is the afternoon session on
interpretability and biological sciences
uh we are supposed to have three
speakers uh debbie marks from harvard
unfortunately is not feeling well so she
canceled at the last minute we all hope
she's feeling much better she was
extremely apologetic and felt guilty
that she's not here so so let's wish her
well um so that's why we had a little
more time at lunch uh anchul
kandaji um
is going to talk about interpretable
models of functional genomics so he's an
assistant professor of genetics and
computer science at stanford
he leads the integrative analysis
efforts for their large-scale genomic
data generation efforts things like
encode and the roadmap epigenomics
project
his lab develops machine learning models
of gene regulation and they've developed
a suite of interpretation frameworks
which is going to be interesting for us
to decipher causal sequences of the
syntax regulatory dna elements um and
you know basically they're going to
train neural nets uh and those things
are going to learn representations of
dna pathways uh and then they're going
to figure out how to extract global and
local explanations from those neural
nets which is great and it's what uh
anshul calls an interpretable lens uh
for genomic discovery which sounds
really fun okay take it away
uh thanks so much rich uh can you can
you all hear me
probably
yes awesome okay um so firstly thanks to
the organizers for um for this great uh
meeting i wish i could be there in
person but um hopefully next time um
so right like rich said um
the theme of my talk today is on
decoding the sequence syntax of gene
regulation and functional genetic
variation
um and we're going to use you know deep
learning models and interpretation
methods to try to accomplish these tasks
um so just want to start with a brief
introduction for those who aren't too
familiar with you know genetics and and
molecular biology as you know there's a
ton of diversity in human populations
some of this diversity is encoded in our
genomes
each of our genomes contain um
genetic variants these are locations uh
where the sequences
vary across individuals so for example
this individual has an a at this
position this individual has a c
and so forth and of course
we carry two copies of the genome in
each cell in our body um so you know
each of us can have
uh same versions of these letters
uh in the two copies or we can have
different versions right
and so some a lot of this variation that
we see in genomes um often doesn't do
anything it's just sort of random
variation neutral variation uh some of
it actually influences uh completely
benign traits you know like
the color of your hair height and there
are of course variants that can
influence
susceptibility to diseases
and disease progression you know like
coronary heart heart disease um so
effectively cataloging genetic variation
in human populations is one of the first
essential steps to
understand the genetic basis of traits
and diseases
and
over the last several decades
there has been a revolution in
sequencing technology the sequencing
machines have gotten smaller the
throughput has
grown at a super exponential
rate and this has allowed population
scale sequencing what this means is that
we can now basically sequence genomes of
millions of individuals
we can do this just to profile genetic
variation
in healthy individuals
thereby
getting a landscape of what natural
genetic variation looks like here's just
some examples as i mentioned before each
of us has two copies of the genome so
this individual has an a and a c
at this position this individual has a a
this individual again has ac
so this is quite nice we can start
cataloging natural genetic variation but
we can also use the same strategy to
profile genetic basis of disease and the
way that's typically done is you
sequence a whole bunch of healthy
individuals and then you have
a collection of of cases uh individuals
that may be suffering from some disease
and you can sequence their genomes and
you can perform a simple association
studies
these are literally just cataloging
frequencies of
alleles are versions of these genetic
variants in the control individuals in
the cases and you can perform
simple univariate association tests
to obtain
variants that appear to have
statistically significant association
with with any disease of interest it's a
very popular technique called
genome-wide association studies and this
has allowed us to by us i mean the
community to catalog
a lot of genetic variants
some common by common i mean variants
that are quite frequent in the
population
and uh there are also rare genetic
variants present in just uh you know
less than let's say 0.1 percent of the
population there are even like
private variants that only a single
individual has and so forth so we can
catalog genetic frequency of genetic
variants we can catalog their
association with different traits and
diseases and this has been a very
powerful strategy to
really sort of profile genetic
landscapes
but then the big question happens okay
so if if i identified a genetic
variation that has association with
let's say
coronary artery disease
what can i do with it so the next
question you typically will ask is if i
find this genetic variant of interest
what is its function or how does it
affect cellular function or you know
disease function or human function right
these are really important questions and
so
we're going to focus on this question as
to how we can decode genomes and try to
understand
the potential consequences of of
individual letters in the dna as well as
words and syntax and patterns
um so to understand the genome we first
have to like you know dive a bit into
the functional anatomy of the genome so
here's a very simple cartoon version of
this here's a cell here's the nucleus
you have some dna we're unspooling it
you can see some of it is wrapped around
these proteins uh protein complexes
and this is referred to often as
chromatin i'll talk about that briefly
uh throughout the talk uh but let's just
go into this section of the genome we've
opened it up and here you see um genes
genes are pieces of genome of the genome
that directly code for proteins they get
transcribed and translated to proteins
um and whether it defines a cell's
function is really the repertoire of
genes that are expressed um and every
cell has its own recipe of genes that
are expressed and depressed um
and um
alongside you know the expression of
genes if you're if you're just precisely
controlling which genes get expressed
and repressed at which levels in which
cells you need a control system
a control system as well sorry just give
me one second
so um
the control system that controls gene
expression also happens to be encoded in
dna and they are typically in the form
of these control elements or regulatory
elements these are short segments of dna
and they essentially act as landing pads
for various proteins
whose job is to regulate gene activity
and what these proteins do is they have
evolved dna binding domains that
recognize a fuzzy dna words
and um
the genomes of these control elements
the sequence of these control elements
have evolved pretty interesting syntax
uh combinations of these dna words in
specific configurations density
orientation
and they really define the specificity
of which proteins
can bind and what configurations to at
which positions in the genome next to
which genes to activate or repress them
in different subjects
so a big open question has been uh you
know what is the
uh what is the syntax that evolution has
encoded in these in these uh regulatory
control elements and there are millions
of them in the genome
um and they're scattered all over the
place the the human genome is three
billion bases
the protein coding pieces of the genome
just about occupy about one point five
percent of the three billion bases so
there's a lot of
free space um and these control elements
are sparsely distributed all over the
genome okay so we're gonna try to
focus on this question of decoding
sequence syntax of regulatory dna
and the other reason this is important
is we're just going back to the original
you know question of disease variation
uh genetic variation um you know as i
mentioned before there are variants that
can um
that that that are different across
individuals right so this you know one
individual has a c and this is present
usually in let's see how the individuals
and g and the g sequence
sorry the g the g ladder at the same
position all of a sudden confers uh some
kind of disease risk so how does that
happen well uh it could happen through
many different mechanisms but you can
think of two potential
you know ones that are pretty prominent
one is that the mutation or the genetic
variant could disrupt the sequence of
the gene itself which would affect the
protein that's produced of course that's
going to potentially have really
devastating consequences the protein if
it's mangled and messed up it's going to
cause very severe
disorders so a lot of rare diseases are
typically caused by mutations inside
coding portions of genes that actually
you know tear apart or mutate proteins
itself
but a lot of common diseases that
typically occur in relatively you know
healthy human populations you know
affected mostly affected affect people
in their older age and so forth um they
rarely affect gene sequences directly
but they usually affect control elements
so you have mutations present or
variants present in control sequences
and they affect the regulation of genes
and you can imagine over time the system
starts breaking down
with specific configurations of genetic
variants and in the presence of specific
environmental stimuli uh this you know
this effect can be pretty severe right
uh so we we're gonna try to um
you know also understand what these
variants might be doing
and for that we need to can i ask a
clarification question the last slide
yes if you were to change the spacing of
the control elements does that end up
having a large impact
yes um
it is a smooth it's typically a smooth
function um spacing does have an effect
of where the control elements are it's a
pretty flexible distributed syntax in
terms of where the control elements lie
but it's basically sort of like a
geometric decay function from the start
of the gene to where the element lies on
average
and so the influence of an element
is sort of
related to the distance of the element
from the
gene you know start site
but not linearly it's typically uh more
of a power law
is there evolution reason for this like
usually the genes seem to be more stable
and then the control elements
now the stable is that yeah to look at
it yes it it it actually allows
incredible evolutionary plasticity so
you know like
uh
as as species have gotten more complex
it's not by creating more and more genes
right it's it's a pretty
reasonably small repertoire of proteins
26 000 genes that's all humans have
the complexity kicks in by really
combinatorics right so which genes you
express and how in what levels in what
in what combinations can give rise to a
tremendous repertoire of gene expression
profiles and by
increasing or playing around with the
complexity of the control elements you
can really change the quantitative
levels of genes as that provides
actually tremendous flexibility and also
by keeping genes
protected right
just through natural selection
um
you can you can play around with with
control uh with the control elements in
a much more flexible flexible way so
that's one of the reasons why
um there's such sort of
diversity in the in the control
sequences and there's lose
conservation there's lose pressure to uh
to keep them exactly intact because it
allows for evolution and adaptation and
so on
compared with drosophila like we share
95 percent of genes and like 70 of the
control elements that's right i mean you
can go all the way to east and we we
share a lot of genes even with east
right so um it's it
the conservation of the level of genes
is is very high
uh but uh control elements uh uh new
neo-functionalize and there's lots of
unique elements uh in every species and
through adaptation thanks
all right so if you want to figure this
out we need some data right so i told
you where we can get genetic data from
but that doesn't tell us about
functional
properties of dna so luckily what we can
do is um there has been a revolution in
using sequencing technology to actually
profile molecular properties of dna so
for example this protein this black
protein binds these positions to
activate these genes we can perform one
experiment that gives you a beautiful
profile across the entire genome and
tells you where this protein binds it's
like a it's like a signal a quantitative
readout at every base in the genome and
so you get a readout and you can do this
for all kinds of molecular markers as i
show you here and these markers can
decorate the genome
showing you dynamic activity of the same
genome in all kinds of cell types cell
states you know healthy
disease
across individuals across cell types and
so forth right
so this has been a very powerful
molecular profiling tool so this is a
complement to genome sequencing
and as i mentioned before uh when you're
interpreting genomes you need to
interpret the genome in the context of
different cell types because all cell
types in a in an individual have the
same genome but they give rise to
completely different properties and
functions right um so
what nih has funded over the last uh
almost uh two decades is large projects
like encode and roadmap what they've
done is they've created just as you have
the reference human genome they've
created a reference molecular map of the
human genome and this is not a simple
sequence it's actually a
three-dimensional
cube of information but one axis is the
genome the other axis is hundreds of
different kinds of molecular readouts
thousands of proteins different kinds of
chemical modifications to dna gene
expression levels and all of this is
done in hundreds and thousands of cell
types tissues individuals cell states
and now we can do this at single cell
resolution so it's a huge amount of data
and we can use this data to now make
sense of how the dna sequence this three
billion base pairs how does it encode
all this diversity of information right
so we're going to use machine learning
models trained on these data to do two
things to decode uh
the sequence syntax of these um control
elements and then to use amorous oracles
to predict effects of mutations in
silicon okay and and also interpret the
models and understand what these
mutations might be doing
all right so part one
so our models are very simple
unlike most applications in machine
learning our neural networks are not
super complicated they're actually
pretty simple they they are their goal
is to take the dna sequence
three billion letters right a sequence a
linear sequence of three billion letters
which is uh
an alphabet of four which is nice and
easy acgd so you one hot encode these
sequences and we build convolutional
neural networks they are
you know they are they have about
10 15 layers at max they're dilated
convolutional neural networks with
residual connections they have
reasonably large receptive fields and
the goal is to try to map these
sequences to profiles
of molecular profiles from experiments
at single base resolution so the neural
network basically encapsulates
a mapping from genomic sequence to
molecule activity of a specific readout
in a specific cell type right so there's
one model for every experiment okay
and once we have this model uh we use
we've developed and used several
methods for very simple feature
attribution so we have a method called
deep lift which is a fast backdrop based
method similar to saliency maps but
slightly different we use finite
difference propagation instead of
infinitesimal gradients and there are
advantages to this approach we have
other approaches for propagation
approaches like fast ism but in the end
what they do is they can take the model
look at a prediction of the model and ba
and try to infer contribution scores of
individual basis in the sequence
and so these models actually we've
applied them to now thousands of data
sets and they happen to be extremely
accurate so
here i'm showing you just some
predictions from the model the each of
these are these are four different
proteins that are binding some location
in the genome this squiggly patterns
think of them as like a shadow of the
protein
um so you get these little spikes right
where the protein binds and we're trying
to predict the shadows of the protein
from sequence alone right and so we show
i'm showing you predictions here from
the model at single base resolution uh
this is the observed data this is a
predicted data this is on held out
chromosomes so we train the models on a
subset of chromosomes and we predict on
an entirely headed out subset so the
models are never seen a subset of the
chromosomes right
and they can do really well you can see
that they can really get
these patterns extremely accurately and
different proteins are different shadows
and it can capture in the same cell type
this is in mouse embryonic stem cells um
just looking at four proteins there are
thousands of these and we are modeling
all of these but i'm just showing you
four of them you can see all four of
them bind this element they all have
different shadows they're binding at
slightly different places right
and if we just evaluate this across the
entire chromosome using a jensen shannon
divergence metric comparing the observed
profiles to the predicted profiles at
single base resolution then what we see
is the red curve is our performance
of the model against the ground truth um
the uh blue curve is is concordance
between replicate experiments if we did
the experiment twice how similar would
it be
um that's sort of our upper bound and
then the gray and the green line are
various like random you know shuffled
bass line and average bass line and so
forth so we are obviously much better
than the bass line and we're approaching
a slightly you know uh
worse than replicate concordance our
models are really really doing a great
job pulling sequence
features out to be able to predict
profiles
now we can use this uh as i said before
we can now start trying to understand
what these sequences are doing so
biologists often want to ask okay here's
um this is a distal control element that
regulates this famous gene called arc4
which is used to reprogram cells
and um i want to understand like okay i
see this kind of binding signal right
this activity signal and these four
proteins
are binding that that particular piece
of dna you can see that shadows right
here
we can use a neural network so there's
four neural networks or a multi-task
neural network trained on each of these
tasks and we can just interpret uh using
feature attribution which basis in the
sequence are driving binding and i can
use the word driving because there is a
causal flow of information from sequence
to binding in this particular case this
implicit causality
so you can see that um you know deeply
for example highlights
some features that are pretty common to
all four proteins and then there are
specific features like this one right
here this little dna word tg80
it pops up specifically for analog and
then there are these ggg sequences that
pop up specifically for klf4 and we can
map these back to known dna binding
words and really start tearing apart the
precise basis and the g in the sequence
that are driving binding of different
factors right this is very simple
feature annotation
now we can do this for millions of
elements in the genome
and we might want to summarize what are
the global patterns of the models are
learning what are these discrete sort of
dna words
obviously they're being repeatedly used
in many many thousands of sequences so
using feature attribution we can of
course interpret individual sequences
but there are millions of them can we
somehow summarize
all the patterns we see
um you know the elemental patterns
across all the sequences so we have a
simple distillation framework where we
use attribution
methods to get contribution scores of
every base in every sequence of interest
then we can effectively throw away
pieces of the sequence that appear to be
unimportant through the lens of the
model
and then we can use a simple um
alignment and clustering procedure so
for example we align
and
align subsequences that appear to be
similar using custom distance metrics
and then we cluster these using you know
graph community detection methods into
and then we collapse them into
consolidated motifs this is a very nice
way to take the millions of parameters
of the net and sort of compress it into
a
very interpretable set of
compact non-redundant words that are
repeatedly being used
across these sequences for proteins of
interest
and for example when we do that for
these four proteins we pick up a pretty
complex repertoire of
of dna words required for just four
proteins to bind so i remember there are
six thousand right so it's not that each
protein recognizes just one word uh
there's complex combinatorial
cooperative binding and so to explain
binding of four proteins we actually
need 50 motifs and each of them has
different combinatorial activity
they have different kinds of patterns
they produce different kinds of
combinatorial shadows and many of them
map to previously known
known motifs and we also find many novel
ones which i don't focus too much on
that's there's a very interesting kind
of biological stories we can go into
repeat elements and really tear them
apart and identify lots and lots of cool
biology and this is published already uh
last year
but i really want to focus on the syntax
piece so so far we've kind of done
we've been able to annotate individual
elements and we've been able to
consolidate into digital worlds
but we really want to kind of understand
higher order properties so for example
uh there's been a lot of debate about
the role of spacing you know between dna
words
some people claim that there are there
are hard spacing rules some people claim
there are no spacing rules
and most of this has been done
observationally you just take you know
you scan sequences and you look for
enrichments or different patterns in the
genome and you hope for the best
we can use our model as a predictive
oracle to actually perform synthetic
experiments so we can for example just
create synthetic dna we can insert two
dna words we can move the positions
relative to each other we can also take
real genomic sequences that have these
words and we can mutate them one by one
so this is very analogous to basically
biochemistry experiments that are done
in the lab and and genetics experiments
are done in the lab right so we do in
silicon versions of these
i'm going to show you two of these
really quick
um here's an example of two dna words uh
we just want to understand they are
spacing syntax okay the impact of
spacing between these words what in what
how they influence binding of these two
proteins so we're showing two proteins
and these two proteins are known to kind
of cooperate in interesting ways
i'm going to see if there's some spacing
constrained between these and how they
affect binding so what you're seeing
here is an animation and all we're doing
is moving this protein sorry this dna
word towards this dna word while keeping
the background constant and where we're
just using the models to predict binding
shadows of these two proteins right
and so what we can do is a function of
spacing on the x-axis we can plot on the
y-axis the change in the
strength of the shadow right that's the
y-axis and we can do this for the two
proteins independently so we have two
different models
we see something really fascinating you
see the red protein doesn't care
you know if you as you change the
spacing
it's binding it stays pretty much the
same so it really doesn't care whether
this gold protein nano sits relative to
it
if you look at the nano protein on the
other hand it actually responds pretty
heavily like there's clearly a
cooperative effect and you can see this
enhancement of binding exponentially
rising
and then as you get closer to the as you
can get the motifs closer to each other
you see this beautiful periodicity
kicking
and that periodicity happens to be
exactly 10.5 base pairs which happens to
be the helical turn of dna so dna is a
double helix center and one helical turn
is ten and a half bases
what this is telling us is that
evolution has found a soft syntax you
can see it's not a hard syntax there's
not one spacing that works
the model claims that there is a soft
syntax that drops exponentially as a
function of distance up to 150 base
pairs and there is a preferred spacing
when the two motifs are on the same side
of the helix the two proteins can
cooperate when the two motifs are on the
opposite side of the helix you do not
have cooperativity right this is really
beautiful like a neural network train or
just on data without knowing any biology
has figured out something very
fundamental first of all asymmetric
causal relationship between two proteins
mediated through sequence and a
beautiful soft
spacing syntax that has learned a
helical constraint right so it's really
cool now we can perform the same
experiment without using synthetic
sequences we can actually use genomic
sequences that contain the same two dna
words and we can now look at what
happens in the genome if we just mutate
words and look at effects so you have
these are actual genomic sequences and
here you can see this is the dna word
for op4 this is a dna word for analog we
can mutate this dna word and the model
predicts a complete destruction of
binding of both proteins
we can mutate the other dna word and the
model predicts no effect on the red
protein and a substantial attenuation of
the
uh
the nanoprotein right and we can do this
for all all the elements that contain
the oct4 and the nano word and we can
average
over those positions so we can once
again plot as a function of distance
the effect of spacing syntax on binding
this time in genomic dna right and we
again see uh that that same effect
replicated but a little noisier you can
again see uh the oxford protein doesn't
care and the nanoprotein sees this
exponential rise with a sort of a
helical periodicity the reason this is
not as clean as what we saw previously
is because these sequences are chock
full of various dna worlds so even
though we are averaging over the genome
we can't marginalize out the effects of
just these two words very effectively if
you only look at genomic sequences by
using the synthetic sequences we can
really look at just the marginal effects
of those two dna words
now of course that we just you know the
neural network could be just making
stuff up so luckily we have
experimental tools that allow us to do
the same kind of mutations and
experiments in the genome itself so our
collaborative collaborator julia's
writing us lab she actually took our
models uh predictions
and she actually replicated the
mutations that we predicted would have
specific kinds of effects in the lab to
real crispr experiments and so i'm going
to show you a few of them
this is one locus you can see the model
predicts this as the binding profile for
the sox2 protein
and this is the actual observed profile
so they look really quite similar
the model predicts this dna word is very
important and the model says if you
break these t's and you make them into a
and g
you should see
a complete attenuation of binding at
this position and an attenuation of
binding at this position for the same
protein
and we perform the experiment that's
exactly what we see we see complete
destruction right here and substantial
attenuation at this position
now what we can do is the same
um we're going to make the same mutation
but now we're going to measure the
impact of the mutation in this sox2
binding word on another protein nanog
right so there's two proteins binding
this happens to be the binding word of
sox2
when we mutate again make the same
mutation and this time measure or
predict mannock binding you can see a
pretty big impact this shows an indirect
effect uh stocks to
sox2 is binding to its dna world
influences nanox binding right
now we can do the reverse effect
um
that happens to be
sorry it happens to be um
one second
messed up the animations
oh i have the wrong slide here but um
you know this this this golden line
right here actually happens to be the
nano world and we can mutate in the same
way and when we see that the model
predicts that if you mutate the nano
board it has no effect on
socks to binding the again the
asymmetric causality we perform the
experiment that's exactly what we see
unfortunately i don't have the slider i
have the same slide repeated twice so my
apologies for that but effectively what
we're able to do is perform real crisp
experiments to validate these
predictions okay
um
so this is very nice because we can use
basically the model as in silicon oracle
we can perform thousands of these syntax
experiments and we can really start
tearing apart all the rules of
how you know sequence motifs and
spacing constraints density combinations
all of this influences binding of
thousands of proteins and these proteins
of course regulate gene activity right
now this is sort of a way to understand
just natural syntax right we're not
looking at natural genetic variants yet
uh but we can perform the exact same
kind of mutation experiments with real
genetic variants so here's an example of
an important genetic variant uh some
individuals have a c at this position
and this is known to actually previously
known to actually affect binding of a
particular protein okay so we train a
neural network model on that protein
the model has never seen genetic
variation it's just strained on the
genome
and then the model we use the model to
predict the effects of the two versions
of that variant this is the c version it
predicts a kind of a interesting profile
when we switch it to the g version you
can see this massive
amplification of the binding signal
right so this is great it validates
um you know this this variant has been
known to be uh affecting binding of this
protein and
is also associated with autoimmune
disease
uh the model correctly predicts that
this variant has a pretty big impact on
binding of this protein but as i
mentioned before we can use a model as a
lens and use attribution methods to
infer how this variant is affecting
binding and it tells a really
interesting story when this c when the
when the sequence of the c at this
position
uh you can see that dna world is
basically inactive there is another dna
word right here to the left that drives
this
weak signal
as soon as you switch the c to a g it
creates this really strong dna word and
this dna word and this dna word they
cooperatively affect binding and they
massively amplify binding so we get a
very nice interpretation
of
what exactly might be happening and it
can allow us to design experiments to
test these hypotheses as i showed you
before
so if you apply this to various diseases
like um
like here's an example of alzheimer's
disease right
so this is what's called a genome by
dissociation study and each point here
is a genetic variant there are millions
of these and the y-axis shows the
association of that variant with
alzheimer's so you can see most of the
variants end up doing nothing but there
are these long towers right
this is called a manhattan plot because
it kind of looks like the skyline of
manhattan these
these these are these towers of variants
these are
loci that appear to have strong
statistical association with azimuth
disease right
so we can go into any of these loci and
start dissecting which variants in this
loci are actually functional
so i'll show you one such example here
i'm showing you these kinds of molecular
profiles in
almost 60 cell types from the human
brain
and they look beautiful they can really
capture these elements and their
activity here you can see an element
that is only active
in oligodendrocytes so there's very
certain specific activity
and what we can do is train models on
each of these
so we have a model for every cell type
we can take any genetic variant of
interest and push it through the model
and predict the delta effect of the two
versions of any variant right
and so here's an interesting locus
there are about 165 variants in this
locus the causal variant is hard to pick
up just from an association study due to
various correlation
properties amongst these variants
we can use our models to pinpoint
exactly one variant right here
amongst these 165
that happens to fall in this
very cell type specific element in
oligodendrocytes
uh this element happens to loop and
regulate this picam gene as shown by
this data
and then we can use a model to interpret
what the variant is doing and what the
model tells us is variant is breaking
the dna world
of a protein called foss
so we can produce
pretty
interpretable predictions of what these
variants are doing we can find map the
causal variant we can say what is
potentially doing disrupting the binding
of foss thereby disregulating the picam
gene in a very specific cell type
oligodendrocytes in the brain and
luckily here we had some validation data
that supports our hypothesis
we've done the same thing in autism
these are de novo mutations these are
not germline
variants that are transferred
you know across
[Music]
generations these are dino mutations and
individuals that have autism spectrum
disorder we can even score those this
time we're using data from fetal brain
okay so that the previous data was from
adult brains again we can dissect cell
types
uh hundreds of cell types in the in
these fetal brain developmental time
points
and then we can use our variants to
again score mutations and we can
pinpoint very specific mutations and
specific control elements and specific
cell types affecting specific genes
we've also done this for conjunctival
heart disease and just to cut the story
short um here we've actually managed to
perform crispr experiments in
um stem cell derived
cardiac cells so we have very specific
predictions like this mutation disrupts
binding of the etv protein in a control
element
next to a specific gene in arterial
endothelial cells so we can make these
endothelial cells in the dish and we can
install these mutations
and we can see that the model's
predictions end up validating extremely
nicely they are actually affecting
expression of the target genes by very
very substantial amounts all right
so i'll just stop there and uh to
summarize
um i showed you how we can use large
scale molecular profiling data sets to
start deciphering genome function these
data sets serve as as really nice
inputs
to train neural networks to map dna
sequence to these molecular profiles
they're able to do these with
really amazing accuracy and we can use
simple interpretation methods and use
the models as articles we can do
simulations all kinds of exciting things
to decipher functional dna letters words
and syntax
the models can be used to design
experiments as i showed you actual
genome editing experiments and they're
starting to provide interesting clues
for therapeutic interventions in rare
disease and common disease and so forth
and so with that i'll just thank my lab
we are a purely computational lab and
we cannot do any of this without
our awesome group of collaborators and
our funding sources
thanks
thank you very much angel is there any
quick question
i guess
sure
you didn't say anything about relative
strengths of these
um
binding
to different sites does that better
yeah so um one exciting thing we've
recently been able to do is uh again all
our models are quantitative they're
predicting these profiles at single base
resolution so we can really quantify
effect sizes and so forth and
link them back to biophysical concepts
like
um you know thermodynamic affinity and
so forth and one thing that's been very
exciting is um even though we're getting
feature attributions and all these
exciting predictions
it's been
a little dissatisfying that we can't put
like actual units on these in terms of
like biophysics
but luckily what we've been able to do
is uh we have paper coming out next week
where we we show that the neural
networks in fact learn delta data g's
implicitly and we can be able to extract
these thermodynamic affinities straight
from the neural networks trained on in
vivo data
in the genome so that's super exciting
because now we make a connection between
these completely black box you know
models
with classic thermodynamics which means
in the future we may also be able to
parameterize these models more
excitingly like we can actually have
like imagine having you know neural
network units that actually are
thermodynamically inspired they actually
like have nice you know sigmoid
functions that capture
um
you know relationship in concentration
affinity all of these interesting
properties so uh we will soon be able to
start putting
um
very interesting units on these
predictions which actually will resonate
very well with the biophysics community
that's great on joel and i've got more
questions about that later for the panel
too
thank you very much and we'll see you
about uh 4 30 or just after that for the
panel
thank you